what's going on everyone it's alex mosey
uh ceo of allied prestige labs gym
launch we've done 120 million dollars in
sales the last four years and i have
nothing to sell you
and so today what i want to talk about
is the three entrepreneurial
evil ease of entrepreneurship all right
so these are the three
kind of ease that i that i see over and
over again from the entrepreneurs that
we work with directly in our portfolio
companies
but also in the entrepreneurs that i
talk to in general
the biggest mistakes that are made stem
from these three evil e's
and so what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
i'm gonna walk through all three of them
i'll tell you an easy way to try and
at least attenuate the mistakes that you
can make from them
and then at the end i'll show you the
one that i think is actually the most
evil
of them all all right so the first e
is expectations all right and the reason
that this one is so evil
is that most of the time us
entrepreneurs we think that everything
has to happen immediately right i had an
entrepreneur not that long ago reach out
to me and say hey how can
you know if we work together how can you
guarantee that i'm going to get to a
million dollars a month
within the next six months and they were
currently i think doing
a hundred thousand dollars a month um
and that kind of expectation
and mindset is literally what will
destroy you in business
because what happens is you set these
arbitrary because all the goals are
arbitrary for the most part right
these numbers that in your mind make you
feel good
or make you feel accomplished and you
set these things up there
with not a huge path of getting there
and you put an arbitrary timeline on it
and then you try and force yourself into
it
and so what ends up happening is you
take shortcuts
you make hasty high risk decisions
and most of the time you end up
destroying the business
and taking 10 steps backwards and so
expectations that we set
for ourselves and our teams we want to
be intolerant of anything other than
excellence
but focused far more on the process than
the outcome so if you could shift the
expectations from outcome-based
expectations to process-based
expectations
and then meet that with the intolerance
of excellence right or
tolerating only x links excuse me then
you can help mitigate
expectation evils right where you
basically destroy your business
as a result of thinking that you have to
be
a million dollars a month or a hundred
thousand dollars a month or ten thousand
a month or whatever that number is
for you by x time right what i see again
and again and again of the people who
make way more money
than i do is they have reasonable
expectations that would be unreasonable
to achieve based on process right i have
a mentor right now who
who always repeats the same thing he
says good process drives good results
and i just that's that's been something
i've been trying to ingrain in my mind
good process drives good results
all right so that's evil number one the
second evil
is emotions all right the second thing
that will kill your business
all right if you look at the biggest
ceos in the world you look at the bezos
as you look at
you know you look at you look at monger
you look at buffett you look at all
these guys right
and what you may notice is that they are
very devoid of emotion and it's not that
they're like emotionless people it's
more so that they try and stay as
even-handed as possible
with the decisions and this is just
something that i've observed and so
here's a telltale sign that you can tell
for
yourself if you're if you're suffering
from this because sometimes it's hard
especially for guys
for us to be like i'm emotional right
now right but like we're human we have
emotions
and so if you're if you're looking and
you flip-flop
a lot on decisions as in you're
presented the same data
and one day you feel this way and
another way you feel another day you
feel this way and literally how you
process the decision
flip-flops all the time it's because
you're being subject to emotions
now if you look at the trajectory of a
business and the and the hundreds and
thousands of decisions that we have to
make as an entrepreneur
you could see how quickly these
thousands of decisions can spin this way
or this way on this path
based on your emotions and it can be the
right way or the wrong way
and so i'll give you here's here's two
two pieces to this it's it's very
difficult to eliminate emotions
right but if you can detect when you are
emotional
then you can decrease the speed of your
decision-making which is usually
contrary
to what most people do when they are
emotional they speed up their
decision-making process
when they're in emotions all right and
so if you feel urgency so for me these
are these are things that are like red
flags
if i feel like i have to make a decision
buy
today or whatever most times it's
completely fictitious and made up in my
mind
and so what i try and do is extend the
time horizon between
the the feeling i have and when i
actually decide to take action
i can't tell you the amount of huge
mistakes that i was able to avoid
simply by sleeping it off right giving
my myself
24 hours to think on it right and a lot
of times the entire world looks
different when you wake up in the
morning
and so that should frighten you because
it frightens me how can the world look
so different only you know
after nine hours of sleep right it's
because
our emotional state's different and so
this is a a tactic that i do like
a lot um for managing emotions
so the best decisions that we make
for ourselves in my opinion or that i
have made for myself
have come from a state of contentment
and so
there have probably been moments that's
why when you go on vacation you feel
like you have a lot of clarity
it's because you're in the correct
emotional state to make the right
decisions because you're not operating
from a place of scarcity
right you're not operating from a place
of have to you're not operating from a
place of
deficiency where i am not good enough
right when you're operating from a place
of contentment
um and i'm not saying we're always
content that's not my point
right the point is that you can probably
recognize those times where you sit back
and you're feeling great you know you
have a lot of gratitude for an
experience or
or things that give you perspective and
so it's in those
time periods where you should make big
decisions
for your life and then know that you
made them in the proper emotional state
this is something that
i'm actively focused a lot on for me
because
the being in the correct making the
right call is basically my only job
now it's really just proper decision
making and so
when i sense myself in a well-rested
content
you know full of gratitude mood that is
when i want to look at my most complex
issues my most complex multi-variable
you know decisions and say this is what
i think the best course of action is
and then sticking with that even when
the the the trials and tribulations that
are inevitably going to happen as a
result of the decision later down the
road
and so that's my that's my hack is
i can't get around emotion i try and
extend time horizons whenever i feel
urgency
and then if um if i'm going to make
emotions from an emotional state i try
and go from a place of
contentment and gratitude and if i do
not feel that state i don't usually make
the decision
so think about that so if you have like
moments when you're playing with your
kids and you look back you're like man
life's awesome
that's when you make the decisions that
you need to make about your life
all right because from there you'll be
operating with a much longer time
horizon
and that's i think my way i think this
this is doing it that way will trick
yourself into extending your time
horizon
which ultimately will lead to better
decision making
and the third e um of the third evils
evilly oops
i'm writing down evil um is or are
excuse me
are expenses all right so the first two
one is
what you think should happen the
emotions affect how you think it should
happen
and the expenses are the the the it's
like the cloud and the dirt right
are the things that that we incur along
the way that increase the risk of it not
occurring
right so if you think about expenses in
general they are liabilities they are
risk that we take on
and so if if our goal is as
entrepreneurs is to increase our upside
and decrease our downside right that is
kind of entrepreneurship and business in
general
right then actively thinking about
decreasing our downside our liabilities
is a way of increasing the likelihood
that our expectations are met
right and so one of the biggest mistakes
and biggest evils that will destroy
entrepreneurial businesses
is because they set massive expectations
when they are emotional
and emotionally deficient because they
need to satisfy you know emotional needs
that their parents didn't meet when they
were kids
they then incur expenses that they
shouldn't otherwise have
to meet these demands that are
completely arbitrary and made up in
their minds
right and so i see this one happen all
the time it's like hey we want to scale
we just hired four more people so that
we can scale
it doesn't work that way get the growth
first
and then the growth will pay for the
people
don't put the cart in front of the horse
the only exception to this
is if you have like commission only uh
you know reps like sales reps things
like that
but most other times 99 of other times
when you are incurring greater expenses
it's not like it's it should not be to
quote anticipate growth right growth
will pay the expenses and if you need to
quote delay
something for a smaller period of time
so that you can shore up your
infrastructure
then you can do that and you would be
amazed at how much flexibility
there is right it's much easier to solve
problems with cash in the bank
with with contracts signed and
you're an entrepreneur like solving
problems is what we do right and so if
you're in that state think about how
much you eat like
if you need to if you have the immediate
demand
right you will solve the problem and the
people will come
i promise you all right one of the
biggest mistakes that i mean
i've made this one so many times um i
hired
25 support reps in anticipation of
growth
for our supplement company prestige labs
two years ago and i currently now have
four people that handle more business
than the 25 did
think about that and so what happens is
when you anticipate growth you don't
even know what the growth is going to
look like
and so you basically just put people
there the culture of the team decreases
the morale of the team decreases they're
being less efficient
and when you have lots of people you
don't think about driving good process
right you just think like we'll just
throw more bodies at the problem
and that's a horrible way to go about
business it's also not a good customer
experience in the long run
and so if we can adjust our expectations
to be reasonable and based on process
not outcome by managing our emotions and
making decisions from a place of
contentment
right so that we don't set these
deficient expectations on ourselves and
our business that we have to satisfy
because we must
be a certain way by this time then we
won't incur expenses and risk that is
undo and not necessarily that will
that will likely destroy our business
when it was a hundred percent based on
our
false made-up expectations about what we
thought should happen
should and so when i look at the things
that undo entrepreneurs and
entrepreneurial businesses
these are the three evil e's
expectations emotions
and uh expenses and i told you at the
beginning that i would share the one
that i think is the most deadly
and it's this guy in my opinion
expectations because what we believe
because these are basically beliefs just
said differently right
another way to say this and this is this
is a really a really good way
that i got from a different coach to
reframe beliefs
is she said if you just call all your
beliefs assumptions
they will be far more malleable and
it's such a it's words matter right and
if we call our beliefs assumptions they
become far more changeable
for ourselves and so if i say this is my
assumption
what do you guys think rather than this
is my expectation what do you guys think
see how different that feels
but they function the same way right but
one of them is approachable
one of them is malleable one of them can
take new feedback and new inputs and new
data
and the other one is a must a should a
have to right
and so if we can readjust our
expectations
right and be focused on our product over
delivering delighting the customers
right being intolerant of anything but
excellence in the process
and because of that our emotions stay
more stable because we're not missing
goals that we have to hit
right which then create more scarcity
more deficiency
more more guttural feelings that then
make us shorten our decision-making
loops
that cause poorer decisions and then
cause us to make poor decisions that
create expenses
all right so this is a loop that
self-reinforces and it can either be a
virtuous or vicious cycle
and so it starts at the top and spins
all the way around
and so those are the three evil ease of
entrepreneurship and entrepreneurial
mistakes
that hopefully you can use some of these
tactics
to to avoid all right don't don't hire
before you need it let the growth pay
for the expenses
when you're making decisions try and
extend
the the space this is what i have found
effective for me and try and make
decisions from a point of gratitude
and contentment and then keep the
expectations driven around process
not outcome and if you can keep the high
like keep your high expectations
but keep them on process not on what has
to happen
because when you reverse it the other
way you'll start making terrible
decisions
so anyways i hope that was valuable for
you i hope that makes sense like
you know subscribe all the all the dings
and whistles
that you know youtube folks are supposed
to say so anyways lots of love
keep being awesome i'll catch you guys
on the flip side bye